professor one of the reasons i was and
am excited to speak with you
is because when one goes about this
project of questioning what reality is
and consciousness and so on which is
essentially what concerns this channel
it can be destabilizing there can be
existential dread and what i found that
helped me was something called act
therapy an approach called act and i was
searching for more information about it
a few months ago and your name kept
popping up over and over and since then
i think i've watched all of the material
that has you online
so i'm super excited to speak with you
about act and why don't you start off
with what is act what does it stand for
what is it and how did you become
interested in it
okay
um
so act is stands for acceptance and
commitment therapy
and
act as a psychological treatment
approach it evolved out of the
behavioral analytic tradition
and it focuses on teaching skills for
living effectively even in difficult
circumstances
so act actually is more than just a
therapy it's a framework for living well
and unlike a lot of treatment approaches
or protocols that are tied to specific
symptom presentations or disorders
act is actually applicable to virtually
all people
regardless of circumstances culture
complaint
and i think part of the reason for that
is the premise from which it begins so
act begins
with this fundamental understanding
that pain
grief
loss disappointment
fear these are inevitable features of
living a human life
and
no one escapes it and so the goal of act
is not the elimination
of these experiences or symptoms
but instead
a wholehearted pursuit
of living a valued life
valued life areas like relationships
meaningful work
education personal growth
even in the presence of difficult
emotional experiences and thoughts
so the emphasis on the heart of act is
creating this life
um a worthwhile life that you want both
now and in the future
so
act you know doesn't believe that people
are broken or that they have illnesses
just that they're stuck in
understandable patterns that aren't
working for them based on
their history what they've been through
and so act gives people the tools to
deal with
the opportunities and the difficulties
that life throws our way
um
and in a
nutshell it helps us accept things that
are really difficult to control
and teaches us to commit to doing the
things that we deeply care about
so in a nutshell
that's that's what act has
you know um
is about and
i got into it when i was in graduate
school and i had learned you know all
these other models of therapy
and to be perfectly honest i wasn't
for example traditional cognitive
behavioral therapy um interpersonal
psychotherapy
and
they were fine they were great you know
but it didn't personally resonate with
me you know it was like i'm the expert
and i'm going to treat this person in
front of me using this intervention
and i remember opening up
you know starting to study act and
opening up the book
you know for for the class and
there was this sentence in the first
paragraph of the
main act textbook
and that
the end of that paragraph said the
single most remarkable fact of human
existence
is how hard it is for human beings to be
happy that sounds extremely eastern is
this influenced by eastern approaches
it's absolutely so the other thing it
says is suffering is a basic
characteristic of human life
um and it's absolutely influenced by
eastern philosophy so it has you know
there are six processes and act
and again unlike other treatment
approaches it was built from the bottom
up and so
there were lots of clinical
science studies being done even before
act was presented as a treatment model
and so it pulled from things that were
found to be effective and from the
eastern tradition for example we know
that mindfulness is effective
um and that this basic premise that
suffering is
you know
a part of the human condition and so
act certainly has parts of the eastern
tradition but it's not only that
act as an exposure therapy but it's not
just an exposure therapy act as a
behavioral activation therapy but it's
not just a behavioral activation therapy
it pulls in
different processes that have been shown
to work
over time and puts them into a treatment
package
is it fairly new
it is not fairly new um the first
textbook
description of act came out in 1999
so
act as a package came out in 1999 but
the developers of act had been
researching
for about 20 years beforehand
the different processes like you know
thought suppression you know we know we
we know one of the most consistent
findings in psychology which is hard to
find
is that thought suppression even though
it works really well in the short term
it actually leads to a rebound effect
in the long term you know so trying to
push down thoughts trying to distract
from thoughts trying to run away from
thoughts
very effective in the short term but in
the long term actually has a rebound
effect
so the developers of act had been
researching these processes for a few
decades before they came out with the
treatment model in 1999.
between 1999 and now the research
literature on act has completely
exploded
there are over 300 randomized controlled
trials right now of act
and in general a recent meta-analysis of
the meta-analyses
has shown
that it's either equivalent to other
gold standard treatments
or in some cases can be more effective
more effective
and
enduring what are some of these
understandable difficulties you
mentioned earlier that people go through
so i imagine one may be obsessive
thoughts what are some other examples of
illnesses or
if one doesn't want to consider them
illnesses or whatever you would like to
call them what are some examples of
distresses that people go through that
act seems uniquely equipped to handle
um
i mean again back to just living a human
life i mean
everyone who's
got a pulse is going to be rejected at
some point no matter how
wonderful and and intelligent and
beautiful and successful you might be
you're still going to be rejected by
people in your life you know and that's
going to hurt
we're all going to have an illness in
our life we're all going to face
a medical illness that's going to
challenge us we are all going to face
heartbreak the loss of people we love
in anything that you care about
there's the flip side that it comes with
pain
if you have a child you know
that
you love that child deeply you care for
that child but with that love
comes intense anxiety
about their well-being and their health
and their future right
and so in act they have this saying in
your pain you find your values
and in your values you find your pain
and that means that anything you care
about if you care about a friend
and you care about a friendship and
you're betrayed
right and so
the natural thing like let's take that
for an example you have a friend really
good close friend
and you were betrayed or you felt
rejected
the easy thing to do would be to
withdraw
not talk about it withdraw shut them out
of your life right
and you can also avoid future
friendships
for example because you feel like you've
been rejected and you've been
you know you don't trust and so
it applies to any of life's difficulties
you know going to grad school you have
to be
going to any actually you know
educational
program it's not easy
you have to face criticism you have to
face difficult challenges how do you
face those challenges do you withdraw or
do you face them
so when you ask me like what are the
challenges
i think there's a really far reaching
it's anything in life that
is gonna going to hurt sometimes
and also opportunities you know when
someone says to me like you just said to
me will you come
do this interview
it would really be much easier and less
anxiety provoking to say no thank you
right much easier
but over time if i keep doing that
number one i never learn how to cope
with my anxiety
number two my anxiety starts actually
seeping into other areas because i never
learned how to cope with it
and number three
my world's getting smaller because i'm
not doing something i care about
this latter part sounds like the
exposure therapy aspect but if you were
to avoid it well that's going to make it
worse and if you were to encounter it
voluntarily slowly incrementally on your
terms then it increases your resilience
so are you feeling anxiety right now
i'm definitely feeling anxiety right now
um
my heart like so what is anxiety right
and if you disentangle anxiety what is
it
any emotion has three components it has
the physical
the physical experience so right now
like my heart's definitely racing a
little bit more than maybe the norm
i can feel my throat like a little bit
constricted you know i feel a little bit
shaky so those are the physical
sensations right
then there's the thoughts
now
right now i'm focused on you so you know
there aren't a lot of thoughts going on
but in general like the thoughts are
like before i came in
oh my god am i going to know how to
answer this is i have to blow this am i
going to sound stupid right i mean it's
these are the thoughts
and then the third piece is
the behavioral like urge that you have
that comes with an emotion
you know that's a component of the
emotion and when it's anxiety the
behavioral urge is to run
right it's to say
not going to do this because if i run
in the short term
my anxiety goes down